In the middle of the harsh desert in Peru,...
...surrounded by miles of rolling sand dunes,...
...there's a small oasis that's far from a mirage.
The town of Huacachina has a population of about 100 people,...
...and is one of the few remaining natural oases in North and South America.
It's a popular tourist destination,...
...hosting tens of thousands of tourists each year.
In its heyday, the village flourished as an elite resort getaway for the wealthy,...
...who once flocked to the waters of the lagoon...
...because it was thought to have medicinal properties.
The resort became so popular, it is even featured on Peru's official currency.
Legend holds that the lagoon was created when a beautiful native princess...
...was apprehended at her bath by a young hunter.
She fled, leaving the pool of water she had been bathing in...
...to become the lagoon...
...and the woman herself is rumored to still live in the oasis as a mermaid.